i think one thing is interesting is
because this is a doctor strange sequel
and although he is
first and foremost most in the narrative
he almost plays a third character in his
film i could i completely agree it was
like a
santana album he was like guest starring
on his own
film
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the after show and
today we're going to be talking about dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
taking a deep dive on all the details
answering some of the burning questions
left by the film now we must warn you
this is going to be a spoiler-filled
show so if you haven't seen the film
please turn off right now and come back
to us once you have so you've been
warned you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy uh to help me
along with things today i have a friend
of the i would say a friend of rotten
tomatoes also a friend of the podcast
that i normally host a friend of the
after show an all-around friend karama
the blurred girl how you doing girl hey
i'm so happy to be
talking about this movie as well as
hanging out with you i know this is
gonna be really fun um okay so let's go
ahead and jump right into it so this is
the 28th mcu film directed by sam raimi
and of course it stars our doctor
strange benedict cumberbatch
elizabeth olsen returning as wanda it
has earned 185 million at the domestic
box office the 10th highest domestic
opening of all time doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness according to
our critics consensus labors under the
weight of sprawling mcu but sam raimi's
distinctive direction casts an
entertaining spell so caramel
knowing that this film is rated 75 fresh
on the tomato meter with an audience
score of 87
and at 75 it's the fifth lowest mcu film
how do you feel about the multiverse of
madness as the comic book nerd that i
know you do
well first of all i actually didn't
realize it was that
the the lowest of the fifth floors of
the marvel
movies that's very surprising to me but
i am not surprised at all to hear that
the audience score is much higher than
the critics score this happens a lot
with superhero films but i also think
that this more than any other marvel
film
you really needed to have more than just
a cursory knowledge of the mcu to um to
understand
it's
sam reigned me with a disney marvel
budget you know there was definitely
elements you saw all of those
horror elements that sam remy is known
for which i didn't mind but i do think
they missed out on
the chance to do some really interesting
things with the characters like um so
chills america um so choose america
rather um
i also came away feeling like i did
years ago with age of ultron
where
i was like okay that's a thing it was a
ride it happened
but i couldn't really figure out the
film's purpose or place in the mcu until
much much later
ultron basically is for
that fans might not realize set up so
much of end game and so much of
what was to come after that i kind of
feel like that's what multiverse of
madness did
yeah i don't disagree with you on that
one in fact there's a great article on
rotten tomatoes where i detailed all of
the reasons why age of ultron is
the one of the most compelling entries
in the mcu but only if you look at it in
a retrospective lens which is also one
of the reasons why it was so hard to
film i do feel like these two films and
i'll put the eternals and doctor strange
together are just as you said
placeholder films they are not ones that
are pushing further the
i would say
mcu lore as much as just giving us
ground posts for where we're gonna build
on um kevin feige even said right before
we got shooting that they just now did
their retreat where they really sort of
tried to iron out these big beats over
the next 10 years and in that meeting
they talked about the films that they
already have done and and what they've
done and the shows they've already had
shot that people haven't seen yet as
sort of the only things they're using as
guideposts that endgame really is the
end of a chapter and this is the
beginning of another so i think that's
probably
safe to say is a is a good
uh assessment of where dr strange sort
of lands let's go ahead and shift over
into our movie breakdown section where
we can really sort of talk about these
characters and we're gonna kick things
off with the most talked about moment
from the film that of course is the
illuminati throne room scene where we
get to finally see these cameos that
everyone has been leaking on the
internet reed richards which is played
by john kozinski charles xavier once
again played by patrick stewart mordor
who's played again by chewie atel
ejiofor captain marvel this one is maria
rambo played by
lashana lynch and then black bolt who
folks will remember from inhumans and of
course the fan favorite that everyone's
excited about captain britain that is
agent carter taking the captain america
mantle but
instead she's british i don't even know
how to describe it in the comics the
right way but she is the british version
of captain america there you go uh in
for all intents and purposes so what was
your reaction to the cameos
overall
i wasn't surprised by them being there i
was excited by it
i
am a little annoyed that it was such
used as bait basically
they were all used as bait for the
fandom to do what uh and listen i'm
guilty of it too uh you know get on
social media and speculate and basically
give marvel free marketing you know and
we were all there speculating in you
know
all of the different versions of oh
that's captain marvel no that's nova no
that's you know invincible iron man all
of that fuels and stokes the flames of
the excitement around
um the film
i was
i was annoyed that they got dropped so
quickly i wasn't surprised at how
violently they went out because that's
sam remy um
but uh the only the only death there's
two deaths that didn't make sense to me
actually in that scene that actually
really aggravated me and one was
uh anson mounts black bolt
because essentially
he was so surprised when she nailed his
face
that his mouth that
he
exclaimed and it
he blew himself up which doesn't make
any sense because that means if he's if
black bolt ever had a cold or hiccups he
would have killed himself so that just
didn't make any sense it just seemed to
be like and then dropping a whole
building or a whole column
on a person that can kind of move
planets i just thought all right i get
it we're showing you that these people
exist and then we're getting them out of
the way because
that's what we have to do it was just uh
a little disappointing and ever you know
even though i was in a uh
press screening
everybody moaned
because it was like really
um so it was a little disappointing
that i will say seeing these characters
on screen quickly and then having them
die so quite
to be honest unceremoniously is a lot
but that's kind of what i expected the
minute i saw them because i know you
have to kill somebody on the superhero
level to show wanda's power and i think
that was the moment like you have to
show how dangerous the bad guy is and
although we had seen wanda's power
tangentially
i think like yeah it's weird for me like
this is what's weird for me you know
what it reminded me of it was deadpool
kills the marvel yes universe yes and
that is a very beautifu a brutal comics
run and that's what that whole interlude
felt like and if you watch that comics
run it is almost the exact same tone
beat and like
oh i need to show you just how awful
this can get kind of thing like if i
recall correctly on that one the way
they killed charlie xavier was just
deadpool
let him inside his mind for a minute and
it killed him like and it's such a crazy
and bad way
for charles xavier to go out but it's
almost fitting because again how do you
make a god bleed you don't yeah but also
i'm so tired of seeing patrick stewart
die on screen as a savior can we can
like can we not for like this is the
third time that's true that's traumatic
the only thing that was nice that we saw
there was he was in
charles uh was in
both the wheelchair and the teal green
suit that was from the animated series
and we know that disney is going to be
sort of reviving a version of that as
well as
uh
you know we have these sneaky
moments that they're sticking in for fan
service yes but ideas that feige is
obviously dropping like these are the
the i see you i see the fans and i i
will bring you something in the future
we're hoping
okay
so of the cameos and i'll only say this
i think for me there wasn't a single one
of those that i was like oh i wish they
didn't do this so i can say that and
there was none of them that i was like
oh i wish you had
i wish um this was done like
dramatically different i would just say
with me for the cameos it's a lot of
nitpicking and it's a lot of i just wish
we had more time right like that yeah i
agree mostly
if we had to kick one of the cameos out
of the boat to say
if you may be playing this character
later
i don't know i have a surprising one and
and people are not gonna like it but i
do if they make a fantastic four movie
which i don't think they should because
i've said over and over again there's a
part and a problem with fantastic four
in a modern setting fantastic four is a
movie of the seventies and a in a
i would say a family of the seventies it
is almost impossible in my opinion to
update that like it needs to be like
johnny quest venture brothers for you to
do fantastic for correctly
you know what i'm saying like i do i
don't think you're gonna get your wish
but i do see what you're saying hey the
director's already dropped out but if
we're gonna go down this very i think
ill-informed path of trying to do
another fantastic four movie knowing by
and large that the concept of this
comic book property is cheesy
it is cheese
it is cheesy
if we're going to go down this road
krazynski needs to direct emily blunt
needs to play sue storm so the injustice
of emily blunt not playing black widow
can somehow die a little bit in my heart
because i i literally still am mad about
that if i do you know what's funny i i
agree with you that emily blunt should
play sue storm
i didn't mind kraszynski as freed
richards
and when we get into some of the end
credit scenes and stuff like that i'll
talk about how all of this could come
together i will agree with you on one
thing i don't think we need a fantastic
four movie the way
they've been presented in the past
but i can't see based on what they set
up in this film
the mcu moving forward without them just
there's just too many things that they i
don't disagree with you on the fact that
they're gonna find a way but well i also
think this whole scene was supposed to
be different because there is an empty
chair on that stage and anybody who
knows anything about the comic book
version of the illuminati knows that
that was probably t'challa's chair yeah
so i have a feeling that this whole
thing
was different i heard a lot of people
say it could have been peter's chair too
it could have been peter it could have
been it depends on what um but i think
all the things that all the discussions
they have for about the incursions and
things like that
here's the thing i think the thing that
we both agree is that
uh choices were made and so were edits a
lot of keys
and edits and chopping happened and i
feel a lot of it happened around this
part of the film because even the pacing
changed here
yeah
and we saw so much of it in the trailers
that i feel like
this was set up early on as the money
shots was always going to be in the
trailers always going to be like part of
this big reveal and then it became
probably the most problematic part of
the film from the writer's perspective
when the when the real life timeline got
all screwed up and what's kind of great
about all these you know characters that
we talked about illuminati is
wanda just murked all of them shortly
after their introduction i think one
thing is interesting is because this is
a doctor strange sequel and although he
is
first and foremost most in the narrative
he almost plays a third character in his
film in a lot of ways um
the wanda arc and what elizabeth was
able to do
i i could i completely agree it was like
a
santana album he was like guest starring
on his own
film
um i
listen i thought elizabeth olsen
despite what some of the critics were
saying i thought she did a fantastic job
she had to play so many roles not just
the 616 wanda that we know she also had
to be herself in the other universes and
then possess herself and it got very
meta there for a minute i actually think
she did
a really good job with what was given to
her i wish she had a few more lines
that weren't all just emotionally like
give me my babies you know i wish she
had a few a little bit more to chew on
but honestly i wish a lot of the
characters had had more to chew on um
but i think her uh her performance
overall was actually very very good
yeah i mean i think look i think
elizabeth olsen there's a lot of folks
traipsing around the mcu that have come
in not oscar winners that i think by the
time their time is done will be and she
i put on that list for sure if you don't
believe me she has a great uh early
indie called mary
i think it's like mary
it's about cultism it's like mary
magdalene and it's literally one of the
most raw performances i've ever ever
seen and she is incredible in that one
and ever since i saw that one i knew she
was one of those folks and she shows a
lot of those things here to your point
though
there's just not a lot of mcu movies can
really add a rawness and a depth so this
one had rawness it had violence it had
what could definitely chew the scenery
moments but it didn't have as much depth
as some of other performances i think uh
the mcu has shown before or what it's
capable
of i also didn't think there was much
time
because here's the thing a lot of people
saying oh i didn't get the same feeling
i got with wanda vision i'm like because
this is two hours and it wasn't all her
you know and i think that was that was a
corner that disney was going to paint
themselves into the moment they started
doing disney plus shows and giving us
all this time to work out these
characters over you know six eight
episodes shoving them back into films is
never gonna make them feel as meaty as
they you know they they were before uh
but you know given what she was given i
think she did pretty good considering
that marvel i believe for the next
movie and maybe one after that are
essentially operating
knowing that they did these without
knowing where they were going i still
think they're doing pretty good because
even at the fifth lowest having someone
like sam raimi come in at this point
after having someone like chloe zhao
come in at that point
is really i think going to be
interesting because i feel personally
although aspects of the film didn't work
any time i looked up and said that's sam
raimi i was about it
yeah that's true that's true there are
moments that that worked very well there
there are moments that you you did feel
were not
edited you know out this there are there
are chunks of the film that felt like
this has probably been here since the
beginning
um
i think
wanda's fight at the
carmitage was probably one of them
um
definitely some of that creepy coming
out of the mirror like the ring
and the the mirrors and the glass oh i
just also
the effects in the film not every single
scene you saw how they probably ran out
of time at the end but there were some
really good effects in this movie and
danny elfman needs to get something
because the soundtrack was amazing that
is one thing where i think everyone has
to agree that danny elfman's score was
just so great like a rock opera in some
ways no absolutely and i also think
elfman
when we get into the digetic sound of
that fight which is actually with
musical notes
that that was one of my favorite scenes
in the film and that was a
very uh
uh that was an incredible way of not
just
using the visual and bringing it into
the the the audible but also the way
that it was executed was just so
brilliant that i'm like yeah again
elfman because there were even though
there were it was tonal there were
moments that were obviously uh classical
like you mentioned there was still that
undertone there's there was drums there
was that rock element that brought you
right back out into the uh
into the film itself and i thought
the rainy moments the drag me to hell
moments the the even the big eyeball
monster that was climbing up the side of
the building is is like doc ock climbing
up the side of the building with aunt
may and you know spider-man bruce
campbell who by the way was a hilarious
uh cameo we knew he was going to be in
there somewhere because he always is
yeah um that's a package deal when you
get samurai you get bruce campbell but
having him and then even that call back
with him punching himself for like you
know
two weeks
again call back to ash vs evil dead but
yeah all of
th this is this is what's crazy about it
wanda was at the center of everything in
this however all of the emotions came
outside of her she just was so focused
on one thing that it's kind of hard to
have those ups and downs where some of
that art king was the benedict
cumberbatch character which i think is
sad because unfortunately a middle-aged
man realizing that he has left the best
parts of his life passing by is not
exactly a compelling storytelling plot
in 2022
we've seen this before however what was
interesting was putting the heart
in someone else and having it be a girl
and giving her the power to it there's a
lot of people who had issues with uh her
casting because she was not cast after
latina like she was in the comics
but the i said give her a shot let's see
what she brings to the character because
america was such a strong
showed up knowing what she wanted
this america just felt like a plot
device to make strange and wanda feel
better she did not show up fully
realized
which sort of was sad it was like oh
yeah but she's you know
the you know the first latin queer
character she's queer if she squint you
know i mean if you can see the rainbow
button on her jacket like it's just it
felt like again a lot of fan service but
not a lot of
let's
give some backstory and let's give some
weight to this character now i'm really
hoping we see more in other movies but i
was also hoping that we'd eventually get
a young avengers out of this but he
dropped her back off at karmatage at the
end and so i was like i don't i don't
know i don't know how to feel now like
that was the one thing that did seem a
little weird to me look i definitely
think america was one of those bullet
points that he was just given and it
feels that way i got what people are
saying because this was along with miles
morales two of the most prevalent
afro-latina characters that we've seen
honestly so having it not be the way it
was intended however there's not a lot
of indigenous characters in comic books
and i really feel like this one in
particular is a great place to do that
because so few people even know about uh
native american ancestry within the
mexican heritage or within south
american heritage or hispanic heritage
and latinx heritage in general so again
i'm all for representation i completely
agree that representation is absolutely
needed in all forms but i also come back
to the fact that if there was more
representation overall we wouldn't all
be arguing over one or two characters i
mean overall it was a fun ride i just
wish i saw
more out of america i wish i saw more
a little bit more out of not just the
wanda that was scarlet witch but the
wanda that was in the other universe
that was home with her kids because that
tender moment she has when she confronts
herself i just wanted that to be a
little bit longer i wanted her to
have to really convince her listen
we're going to be fine i am you you are
still existing in this universe you know
i wanted to see more of that
what's really interesting this movie
with doctor strange is it feels very
much the way it felt with captain
america
whereas in captain america's civil war
was avengers 1.5
this has similar vibes and no more was
that illustrated than with cleo strange
although i did not know that charlize
theron was playing clia strange the
minute she popped onto the screen
because there was just not enough with
anything that that character did right
away that signified who she was because
first of all the costuming was very
anachronistic
the
the
like she like it you could tell that
these people would and could bang but it
was more about like where she is and who
she is you know what i mean but there
was not enough for me to really say oh
this is
like you would i would know who jane
foster is the minute she showed up next
to thor
right right i know strangers i think
because they just changed it a lot for
charlize but um what did you think of
her in this moment well it's really
weird because i feel like leaked images
of her showed more of her costume than
we saw in the film
so it was like i kind of knew she was
coming but again not because of what i
saw on screen it was because of rumors
and things that i'd seen you know
across the web um it makes sense
well here's the thing it would make
perfect sense to bring her in to the mcu
because there's something else that i'm
noticing the mcu is actually
for once
getting closer and closer to the comics
they're realizing that it's really hard
i think for fans who might see the movie
before reading a comic to understand
what's going on i will give you black
panther as exhibit a but i've always
found clia a very interesting character
besides the fact that she's doctor
strange's love interest at one point but
like remember dormammu from the first
doctor strange movie how that was the
baddie
claire is basically dora mama's niece
from his sister's side and i'm not even
exaggerating
there's certain characters that don't
have enough of a distinctive look across
generations and like clea is one of them
so like that was the main reason why i
didn't recognize her and
yeah it will be interesting to see where
that character ends up
going with strange because previously
all the stuff that rachel mcadams
character had done with doctor strange
happened with her carry i think this is
more of like this is maybe your fatal
bride type so
i personally think that the doctor
strange in her universe is dead and she
came to this one to get him
because she and him had to fight
together several times in the comics so
i personally think the mcu version of
cleo is like clea is like yeah let me go
get i gotta find him in another universe
because i got things to do and it's
interesting also she's the source for
supreme of the dark dimension and now in
the comics she's the sorcerer supreme of
everything
um so
she she's a very very powerful being
that could be
if benedict cumberbatch did decide like
listen i'm sorry i i have done you know
x movies in decides he's out she could
be
our sorcerer supreme all right so that
wraps up our movie breakdown of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
with our guest caramel horn who you can
find on socials as the blurred girl if
you liked our discussion of the film be
sure to stay tuned for our after
thoughts sections where we go through
some of the lingering questions left by
the film and theorize what could be in
store for the future of the franchise
thank you for tuning in and we'll see
y'all next time